The reason I put so much time and effort
into creating teslow was,
uh,
because,
um,
it,
it has always seemed to me that the,
the,
that,
that transportation,
we'll,
we'll go electric and should go
electric,
but we have an unpriced externality in
the
negative effects of,
of,
of gasoline and,
uh,
on the environment and also in the,
you know,
the wars that we fight and,
um,
national security and that kind of
thing.
Whenever you have an unpriced
externality,
you can't quite,
you can't quite rely on the market to,
to do the right thing.
So in order to have electric vehicles
come sooner than they otherwise would it
electric vehicles,
we're,
we're always going to be the long term
transportation mechanism.
Um,
but to make that day come sooner,
uh,
you have to bridge the gap with
innovation.
Petrus,
the goal with Tesla is to try to serve
as a catalyst to accelerate the day,
um,
uh,
the day of electric vehicles.
And,
and I,
I think,
um,
when,
when all said and done,
I'm hopeful that,
uh,
historians will look back on Tesla and
saint a tesla advanced that by,
um,
at least 10 years,
which at that that would be a huge
victory in my,
in my mind.
And solar city of course is on the
assault,
is on the energy production side of
things.
Um,
uh,
because it doesn't help if we have
sustainable consumption of energy,
but,
but then that energy isn't produced in a
sustainable way.
And I,
I feel quite strongly that solar power
will be the single largest source of
electricity generation,
uh,
by the midpoint of the century.
Um,
in fact,
it just a simple extrapolation of the
growth of solar power would,
would,
would show that that's obviously going
to be the case.
And also when you consider that the
earth is almost entirely solar powered
today,
and that the,
um,
the fact that we're not a frozen ice
ball at say four degrees Calvin and,
uh,
it is just due to the son and the whole
ecosystem is powered by the sun.
There's just an anybody amount of energy
that we need to do complicated human
things.
This is a tiny amount of energy really
compared to what the son puts on the
earth every day,
and we just need to capture a little bit
of that and turn it into electricity.
Um,
so we have to try to accelerate that
with innovation.
And that's what soldiers things about.